The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So I try to do
this at least every other class
so we remember the context.
But class 1, as
you remember, was
all about the
economic growth theory
and the economic growth
context for innovation policy.
And we did growth economics
and how it broke away
from classical economics
around developing
a new theory of growth.
So Solow argued that there's
technological related
innovation.
And we concluded that was a
key direct innovation factor.
So we could loosely,
although in accurately,
translate that concept as
saying, you've got to do R&D.
And then we read Romer.
And Romer argued that
behind that R&D system
is human capital
engaged in research.
That's another foundational
direct innovation factor.
You can't build an
innovation system
without these two
elements arguably.
So it's the R&D and
the talent behind it.
Those give us two
direct factors.
Then in class 2, we talked
about the indirect elements
in this larger ecosystem.
And government controls some.
Private sector controls more.
But that gives us an idea
of looking at innovation
as a system, which Richard
Nelson contributed to.
And then within that system,
you look at the strength
of the innovation actors.
And you can begin to think of
your innovation organization
as a third direct
innovation factor.
And that leads us
into the whole problem
of how do you cross
the valley of death
if you've got a
disconnected model.
Classes 3 and 4 were case
studies on manufacturing.
So we took a deep dive
into a very current set
of practical, ongoing problems
to try and think about some
of those innovation
organization lessons
in a manufacturing context.
Class 5 was explicitly about
innovation organization.
And we looked at David
[? Hart's ?] analysis
of the ideology behind
looking at innovation
in the political system
and the conservative,
the associationalist, which
is the public private,
the national security models.
All those issues are
still very much with us.
And in that class,
we also talked
about Donald Stokes' work
where he critiqued the split
in the US innovation
organizational system
between front-end
innovation, the R
side and the later stages.
So when we organize to do,
essentially, a research
model at the end of World War
II under that pipeline model
that Vannevar Bush
gave us, we missed
issues that subsequently
rose in the economy
and became really deep
sources of problems
about the connections to the
fall of one implementation
back into the innovation
system stages.
Class 6 was about crossing
this valley of death.
How do you build
the bridging models
that get you from a
pipeline innovation model
across to the later stages.
That's not easy in our system.
And then we also
talked about the fact
that we run two parallel
systems in the US.
So Vernon Ruttan's book, Is War
Necessary for Economic Growth,
introduced us into the whole
Defense Innovation system,
which is not disconnected.
That's a pretty connected model.
And the Defense
Department will typically
perform the research,
the development.
It will do the demonstration.
It will do the test bed.
It will move to the
advanced prototypes
and will often provide
an initial market
for emerging technologies.
That's a very different
organizational system
as we discussed from what the
civilian agencies are up to.
Class 7 was innovation at
the face-to-face level.
That's our whole
great group's theory.
So if innovation has to
do with institutions,
which it certainly does--
how are those institutions
organized and how
do they connect
and how are the handoffs
between the actors?
But in the end, people own
innovation, not institutions.
It's very face to face.
And then in the
great groups classes,
you remember well
we talked about some
of the rule sets
that tend to guide
the way in which great
group-based innovation
operates.
And again, that drives us
back to this third innovation
factor--
what does innovation look
like an organizational point
of view, from a
systems point of view,
from an actor's point
of view, but also,
how does innovation look
at the face-to-face level.
And then in class 8,
we talked about DARPA,
which is an institution
that actually attempts
to do both on a good day.
It will support
that connectedness
of innovation institutions
being connected
using that defense model.
But it will also attempt
to build great groups.
And we talked about JCR
Licklider and the evolution
of the IT revolution,
a lot of the origins
of which came out of
DARPA-supported research
as an example of that.
So now, we're going to do some
more case studies in today's
class really looking at the
life science innovation system
and how does that function.
And we're going to take
a lot of the lessons
that we've been learning
and try and fit them
into analyzing this
really important piece
into this territory.
Let me give you a quick
NIH historical backdrop.
Remember the pre World War II
and the World War II context?
NIH just stood up as a
Vannevar Bush basic research
organization.
So Franklin Roosevelt
in Vannevar Bush
see what happens
in World War II.
They see the development of
antibiotics led by penicillin.
And the effects are
breathtaking, absolutely
breathtaking.
So suddenly, we fight a war.
And you probably
won't die of disease.
You'll actually die of
battlefield injuries, which
has never happened before.
And that immediately
has an effect.
It removes pneumonia
from the number 1
cause of death in the
United States conceivably
further down the list.
It's very dramatic.
Bush and Roosevelt see
this and understand
how powerful that model is.
And so one of the theories
in The Endless Frontier
that Vannevar Bush puts
out, as you remember,
is that there's going to
be a war against disease.
And they've just seen
what this model is.
So they want to do it.
Now, Truman, as you remember,
vetoes the one agency,
One Tent National
Science Foundation role.
So he vetoes that in
like, is it '47 or '49?
And that leaves a void.
So voids tend to get filled.
So this little
research outfit that's
part of the Public Health
Service, the National
Institutes of Health becomes
the National Institutes
and really starts scaling up.
So follows a Vannevar
Bush basic research model.
But it evolves in this gap
of organizational leadership
in a way and fills that void.
And then over time,
disease groups
tend to be very
active politically.
If you have a disease or if
a loved one has a disease,
you tend to be very active
in the disease group.
And these disease groups push
their disease in Congress.
And Congress keeps adding
institutes and centers
onto the model.
When it reaches an
unmanageable number of 27,
finally, Congress actually
tries to restrain itself.
But it creates an organizational
model that's problematic.
Now, another feature here is--
here's a line from Tony Fauci.
It's one of the--
He's the director of
NIAID, quite famous.
NIAID was one of the
leaders in getting
on all kinds of infectious
diseases, including AIDS.
But Tony Fauci writes
in 2003, "the path
to product development has not
been a part of NIAID's research
strategy."
In other words, that's
not on the table.
They're worried about their
basic research results.
So what did NIH--
and arguably, the biotech
model that is spawned from it--
what did they get right?
And they get a lot
of things right.
It's an amazing system.
It's a remarkable
story of success.
So even though we're going
to be critical today,
it is an amazing success story.
NIH trained everybody.
It created this huge education
system that put a lot of talent
on the task in Romer's terms.
This knowledge base helped spawn
a remarkable entrepreneurial
biotech startup model.
And we talked about Genentech
during our great groups class.
That's the first.
But that's a very good example
of what then flourished.
And Boyer and Swanson
were the founders.
Boyer comes out of
that NIH-funded system.
Biotechs have been able to
get venture capital support
even though they have a 10 to
15 year stand-up model, which
is a remarkable accomplishment.
No other sector is able to
get venture capital money
unless they're no
more than a couple
of years out of production.
Biotechs have been able to break
that and get long-term support
for R&D.
And the key to this has
been the value of IP.
So there is a working monopoly
model in the biotech sector.
So if you're first
to patent a new drug,
you are given a monopoly
rent for a 20-year time
period minus the
time it gets you
to get through clinical
trials with NIH,
which can be seven years.
So it's a 13-year
run where you're
assured of monopoly rents.
And unlike the hard
technology sector,
it's harder to
stand up, in effect,
copy-cat fixes, copy-cat drugs.
So you really do get a
significant run typically
if you're first
to patent and you
get ahead first through
the clinical trial process.
So that's been the
enabler that allows
this financing system to work.
The other key feature
is FDA's approval.
So FDA gives you--
in stage 1, stage 2,
stage 3 clinical trials,
if you're developing
a cancer drug,
you know exactly
what your chances
are on getting through
the from stage 1
to stage 2 and stage 2 to
stage 3 and from stage 3
to final drug approval.
You know just what
your chances are.
So that enables
venture capitalists
to tee off their
stages of financing
to your success in the
clinical trials process.
There is no benchmarking system
like this in any other sector
in the economy.
It works amazingly well.
And then another big
difference between life science
and everything else is that,
if FDA approves your drug,
you are guaranteed a market.
In fact, our
wonderful legal system
is such that, if a doctor fails
to prescribe the medicine which
is fitted to your problem, the
next day, the doctor gets sued.
So there's this huge forcing
mechanism in the system.
There's nothing like a
certification that guarantees
you a market on the next day.
There's nothing like this
anywhere else in our system.
It's a remarkable thing.
And we can start to
think about how do you
get analogous certification
processes and benchmarking
processes in place
in more physical
science-based technologies.
It would be very interesting.
We haven't done it.
But there's a lot to be
learned from this sector
because of the
system it's setup.
Upstairs-downstairs
has historically
been a problem, particularly
in European science,
but also in US science, whereas
the academic researchers have
disdain for the
company researchers.
That has really broken
up and broken apart
in the life science side.
So outstanding
academics, think Boyer,
who spent time in a biotech.
That's not created as
a sound career path.
Boyer had to break the ground.
He got a lot of flak
for it at the time.
But over time, it's
become accepted
that you can have an academic
career, move to a biotech,
move back to an academic career.
That's OK.
Obviously, this conflict is used
throughout that whole process
that had to be dealt with.
But that's an
acceptable pathway.
So the whole
upstairs-downstairs relationship
between the academy and
commercial development
has really been broken up.
So that's another thing
that this sector got right.
NIH also has a huge
amount of money.
It's by far the
largest R&D agency.
It's got over $30
billion a year.
Nobody is close.
NSF, by comparison,
has $7 billion a year.
The Department of Energy Office
of Science has $5 billion.
DARPA has $3 billion.
So this is an order of magnitude
almost different from other R&D
agencies.
So the political constituencies,
including the disease groups,
have built a very
powerful political base
for sustained funding
in this sector.
Now, that's the good news.
Here's the problem.
We're going to talk about
the innovation train
wreck that lies ahead here.
So the economic model
for biotechs and pharmas
really requires
blockbuster markets.
It's a huge problem.
So in other words, third-world
diseases, infectious diseases,
small-population diseases,
it doesn't make sense
to pursue those.
To get a drug through the FDA
clinical process to develop
in time before, during, and
during the clinical trial
approval process itself, that's
around a $1.4-billion-or-more
proposition.
So unless you're selling
it to a major market,
it doesn't make any sense
to develop the remedy.
So there is a statistic
that some cite,
which is that 80% of our
R&D money in life science
is spent on 10% of the diseases.
That's a problem.
I don't think the
number is that bad.
I think that's exaggerated.
But we've got a
problem here because of
this blockbuster drug model.
Only if you're developing a drug
that sells into a major market
opportunity is it going
to get into the market.
So what does that leave behind?
In addition to the
things I've mentioned,
the precision medicine or
personalized drug model
gets left behind.
In other words,
if each one of you
is going to have their
own remedy variant that's
particularly adapted to your
genetic structure or metabolism
or whatever, what
are we going to do?
Run a $1.4-billion clinical
trial process for you?
It's not going to work.
So how do we deal with this?
There's a huge looming train
wreck problem in the system
because that's where it's going.
These are the benefits of
being able to use big data
and analytics to develop
personalized medicine.
But if there's not an economic
model to get it there,
it won't happen.
The litigation threat makes
drug companies risk averse.
So we leave a lot
of promising stuff
on the table because
of that threat.
Often, a drug will
cure, let's say,
20%, 30%, maybe 40% of a
disease group's problem.
But if it kills
some people, we'll
never go to market because we
don't understand the precision
medicine, the
personalized medicine
implications of these things.
And until we do, we're
just leaving a lot of stuff
on the shelf that has potential
value because Americans,
for good reason, have very low
tolerance for risk from drugs.
The health care spending in
the overall system by 2025
may account for
9% of GDP or more.
And we'll talk about
this in a minute.
But we can't afford a health
care bill of those dimensions
and still have
other things going
on in the society and the
economy and the government.
This is what we spend money
on in the federal government.
This is what we think
of as government.
So that's like the national
parks and federal research,
transportation, highways.
That's this.
That's defense.
So that's actually about 16%.
And that's now about
maybe a little below 20%.
That's Social Security.
That's Medicaid,
Medicare, and SCHIP,
the big health-care-oriented
entitlement programs.
That's other safety
net programs, 9%.
And then we have interest on
the debt, which is actually now
over 9%.
So as you can see, the
federal government is mostly--
we're talking 60% plus
interest in the debt--
a check-writing kind
of organization.
And that's what we
think of as government.
And that's what we think
of as the domestic side
of government.
So these are pretty
small pieces.
Rasheed?
AUDIENCE: What year is this for?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: This is
probably about four years old
now.
But the numbers are slightly
even more problematic
than these.
So again, this
category is now 16%.
So the numbers are probably
off by a couple of percent.
But it's a problem.
And as we'll see
in a second, these
are components of
federal spending.
So that's health.
And that blue line
is everything else.
So you can see where
taxpayer dollars are going.
This kind of demonstrates
that Social Security is not
the real problem.
It's really the health
care cost related
to Medicare and Medicaid
that are the problem.
This shows historic
levels of taxation.
Remember, the United States
was founded on a tax revolt.
So we're not going to
have European-style levels
of taxation in
the United States.
It's just not going to happen.
And we start to run into
real political trouble
once you get a little bit above,
say, the 20% level of taxation
that's a percentage of GDP.
So we're headed way up against
that threshold largely because
of the demographics and
the health care spending,
which means that, broken down
this way, the percentage of GDP
we spend on, what we
consider most of government,
is just not going
to be affordable
given the acceptable
levels, around 19%, 18%,
the acceptable tax range
in our political system.
So Max?
AUDIENCE: What are [INAUDIBLE]?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Expenditures
by the federal government.
What they're spending
in a given year.
What they were actually
outlaying to meet their costs,
to meet their obligations.
So these are some of the
problems that lie ahead.
We got a real fiscal
train wreck because
of the cost of this
health care system driven
by the demographics.
My generation
attempted to make you
spend all of your money on me.
That's essentially
what's going on.
It's a massive intergenerational
transfer of wealth.
And you guys need to wake up
to that because it forgoes
opportunities that you have.
And at the heart of this
is a really serious problem
with health care expenditures.
So let's now get back
into our main themes.
This was a classic 2003
report, what is now
called the Academy of Medicine.
It used to be called the
National Institute of Medicine.
It's part of the
national academies--
they did on evaluating NIH.
And it was a pretty
startling criticism.
And they looked hard
at this NIH system.
It really began to identify
some of the problems.
Interestingly, this report drove
some interesting congressional
reform attempts.
Let me see if I can summarize
a few key points here.
And Chloe, did
you have this one?
You've got it, Martin?
OK.
All right.
So as I said, NIH is more
like a feudal barony.
It always has a famous director.
But they don't have that much
control over these institutes
and centers.
There is no
centralized budgeting.
And the institutes
and centers battled
to protect their percentage
share of NIH's total budget.
So Harold Varmus, a
famous former director
of NIH, who later came back
in the Obama administration
as head of the National Cancer
Institute, he said, in 2001,
"NIH would be more efficient
and more manageable
if a far smaller number
of larger institutes
existed organized around
broad science areas."
Less institutes, organized
around science areas
is his twin points here.
And there's a lot to
be said for that case.
Instead, as we
discussed, the institutes
got set up essentially at
the behest of disease groups
to solve their disease problem.
It turns out there
isn't a separate pathway
for each disease.
It turns out there's a
lot of common pathways
across a lot of diseases.
And we don't have a very
good mechanism in NIH
for getting groups of
institutes to collaborate
on a cross-cutting
set of problems.
So fundamental
organizational issue.
Now, there is another side
of this argument, which
is, you've got a
lot of institutes
with a lot of freedom
to do a lot of stuff.
Maybe a desegregated
model is not all bad.
There's certainly a case
to be made for that.
But overall, there's
a challenge here.
And NIH's budget doubled
from 1998 to 2003.
So there was a federal
surplus in its budget
during the IT revolution,
which was generating
huge amounts of tax revenue.
And two US senators saw
this emerging surplus.
They were on the appropriations
subcommittee that handled NIH.
And they went to
the Senate floor
and took a noticeable
part of that surplus
and gave it to NIH.
It was a fascinating political
development, very shrewd.
Arlen Specter of Pennsylvania
and Tom Harkin of Iowa
were chairmen and ranking on
the appropriations subcommittee.
And they created the doubling.
It's a remarkable story.
They were able to
do it because there
was so much excitement
at that time
over the genomics revolution.
So we talked about Venter
and the NIH dueling battle
[? Collins ?] over who's going
to get to the genome first.
There was creating
huge excitement.
It was a sense that
this medical research
could lead to all kinds of new
fundamental understandings.
Everybody was excited
about the idea.
And that enabled those two
senators to double NIH.
No other agency has ever been
able to do anything like this.
The rest were stagnating.
But the demographics
are changing.
The patterns of
illness are changing.
We have a threat of biothreats.
Is NIH too fragmented to cope
with all these challenges?
Can it respond quickly enough?
These are all issues
that the report raises.
It wants to avoid
proliferation of new agencies.
And in fact, Congress
did that as part
of its reform legislation.
You can't have a
new institute in NIH
unless you close
down another one.
The Institute of Medicine, and
now the Academy of Medicine,
urged in this report that NIH
focus on its capabilities.
And it needed to do so because
it concluded that NIH is not
only imperfect, but nobody would
have ever designed NIH this way
at the outset.
And in fact, Elias
Zerhouni once told me
in a meeting and
others, if only we
had thought through the
organizational model
before we doubled.
So we doubled first.
And then there
was a mad scramble
to grab the money from
the existing institutes.
If only they had thought
about the organizational model
up front.
Zerhouni led a great
effort to try and get
cross-cutting research efforts
going across the institute.
So he created what he
called the roadmap.
But essentially,
then Congress later
institutionalized that
as the common fund.
Take a little bit of
money from each institute.
Create a common fund in the
control of the director who
can then allocate
it to the highest
cross-cutting priorities.
So that was a
significant reform.
But it's still a very
modest amount of money.
NIH needs to pursue
an ability to go
after high-risk,
high-return projects.
That reaches a certain stage.
And we'll talk about
this more later.
But peer review is not
good at taking risk.
If there's a certain
level of competition,
if the award rate gets higher
than about one out of three,
your ability to identify
breakthrough opportunities that
are feasible gets harder.
So it tends to default to--
when there's a lot of
competition for an award,
the one that the peer
community is most confident
will yield results, albeit
they be incremental results.
Why take risks on high
flyers when you've
got to get the basics done.
And so many people are
fighting for the money.
So this is a huge
problem at NIH.
How does it take the
necessary risks that
need to be taken in innovation?
So since then, NIH
has been working
on creating categories
of higher-risk projects
that have a separate
kind of review
process than normal projects.
So there are positive
NIH capabilities.
We talked about
how decentralized
can be an advantage.
We talked about many
setting R&D priorities.
You get a lot of
safety nets here.
There are benefits to
investigator initiative grants.
You don't want to just
have large-scale projects.
You want bottom-up
opportunities.
The issue for NIH, though,
is, historically, it's
been totally
dominated by bottom up
and has a modest number
of cross-cutting projects.
Peer review in some ways is like
Winston Churchill's definition
of democracy, the worst
possible system except
for all the others.
So peer review
remains competitive.
And that's a very important
feature to build in.
So [? IOM ?] recommended much
more centralized management
giving more authority
to the director of NIH,
getting the director to
engage in strategic planning
across the institutes so they
got on to cross-cutting plans,
doing cross-cutting budgets.
So this idea of take
10% of the budget
and fund the strategic
plans, actually, Congress
worked on implementing that
through the common fund.
Strengthening the
control of the director
over these cross-agency
initiatives was key.
They also recommended
creating a DARPA within NIH
to go after the high-risk,
high-reward projects.
They wanted improvements in
NIH as intramural programs.
So NIH is also a major
research entity itself.
It's not just funding
universities that historically
has tended to be somewhat
weaker than the university
research, which is much
more competition-based
rather than kind of
entitlement-funding-based.
They wanted to strengthen that.
There is a desperate
need for standardization
of data and information
systems across
these different institutes.
Because a lot of these
diseases are related,
they can learn from each
other and you can't do
cross-cutting data analytics.
So there is a series
of reform steps here.
As going back to some earlier
points we've made in the class,
NIH is not a connected
organization.
It's an early-stage basic
research organization.
It's not connected to
the following stages.
Now, it has managed to create
a model through biotechs
that are venture funded
that is able to get
across the valley of death if
you've got a blockbuster drug.
That's pretty creative.
Other agencies haven't
come up with that.
It's not as if NIH was sitting
around figuring it out.
But in effect, it occurred
and the training of the talent
helped it occur through
people like Boyer and Swanson.
Martine?
AUDIENCE: Will we
define blockbuster drugs
as the one that makes
a lot of money or one
that impacts the disease
that a lot of people have?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: One
that makes a lot of money.
Right.
I mean, in theory, it won't get
through FDA unless it actually
solves a problem.
NIH is primarily
small-grant research
and lacks the
capability to set up
initiatives across
the stovepipes
as we've talked about before.
It tends to be
fairly slow moving.
There's a risk in peer
review of avoiding
high-risk, high-payoff
approaches.
There's limited
connections to industry.
In other words, that
translational research effect
is hard to do it at
NIH, although Collins,
who's the current
director of NIH,
has worked on creating a
special translational medicine
institute designed
at that problem.
So NIH has been
taking steps on this.
I think that's a pretty good--
I'll give you one more example--
nanotechnology.
The earliest beneficiary
of nanotechnology
was probably the
semiconductor sector.
But the life science sector,
the health research sector
was very close.
Huge potential,
opportunity spaces
in understanding things
at the nanoscale here.
Because of the disaggregated
structure of NIH,
for many, many years after the
nanotechnology initiative was
created, NIH--
by far, the largest
research organization--
was only spending a fraction
of what the National Science
Foundation was spending
on nanotechnology, even
though the gains for the
health research system
were, and clearly
are, phenomenal.
So that's an
example of a problem
in being able to attack
a whole new approached
disease across this very
disaggregated model.
So that's the IOM
report of 2003.
We've learned some
lessons from this.
We tried to make some changes.
And Congress has actually
provided a fair amount
of leadership on that in
creating the common fund
and capping the
number of institutes.
Martin, you want to take us
through some questions in this?
AUDIENCE: Do you actually want
to do the Cooke-Deegan one?
Because that way I can
just integrate them.
And it might be easier.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
We can do Deegan
and do it together.
And we don't need to
spend a lot of time
on this because last
week's class was on DARPA.
So I'm not going to recap this.
Robert Cooke-Deegan was
deputy when Watson was heading
the Genome Project at NIH.
So he knows NIH from the inside.
He later went on to head
Duke's Genome Institute.
So he's an outstanding
researcher.
And now, he is teaching
science and technology policy
at the Washington
branch of Arizona State.
So he's gone over to the
dark side of science policy
where people like me
inhabit the world.
But he's got real talents,
unlike me actually,
on the technology side.
And he wrote this piece
back in 1996 fairly fresh
off his own NIH experience,
Does NIH Need a DARPA?
And I can't tell you how
controversial this was.
NIH has always viewed itself
as better than everybody else.
And the fact that
one of their own,
the deputy director of
their Genome Project,
was telling them there was a
better model out there that
they ought to at least
consider adopting for part
of their operation--
certainly, not for all--
was a powerful message.
And we know the DARPA story.
So I'm not going to recap that.
Robert Cooke-Deegan underscores
that the DARPA model
suggests that peer review is
not the only way of organizing
research.
DARPA has far lower transaction
costs than NIH does,
a lot lower review costs
per science direction.
He introduces this issue of how
conservative peer review gets
when it gets to an
award rate that's
much worse than about one out
of three applications per grants
awarded.
NIH has got a very
limited ability
to do the grand challenge model,
to pursue that challenge model.
It's got limited ability
to take high risks
and get high rewards.
It's got a lower risk
acceptance capability.
Those are DARPA things that NIH
should have-- not all of NIH,
but certainly some part of
it-- might adopt, he argues.
He cites a lot of examples.
The Human Genome
Initiative actually
originated in the
Department of Energy
because the Department of Energy
understood supercomputers.
So for the first five years
of the Genome Project,
it was carried by the
supercomputer gurus
at DOE, because
they understood what
the potential supercomputing
was going to be in figuring out
the genetic structure.
NIH only picked it up when it
saw the promise of the model.
NIH had terrible trouble
coping with the advances made
by Leroy Hood.
And we'll talk
later about Venter
and how do you adapt
and incorporate
a computational model
in medical research.
They're locked into a
biology-only drug development
model pretty much.
It's hard for them to
do other territories
as we'll talk about when we
get to the convergence report.
So the lessons from
DARPA for handling
multidisciplinary approaches in
bringing in a group of talent
around a problem that comes
from different fields, there's
lessons here for NIH.
I mean, that's the heart
of Robert Cooke-Deegan's
recommendations.
And Martine, it's yours.
AUDIENCE: So I think you did
a good analysis of the papers.
So I won't really
summarize too much more.
I think we can just go
straight into discussion.
And so I think a good first
question would be, how do we--
know that there's a lot of cost
in the health care industry
and this system, the structure
they have isn't perfect.
And so how do we create a system
so that these problems that
need to get solved but don't
have economic incentive
because they're
not blockbusters,
how do you combine NIH with
maybe some DARPA-like abilities
and industry?
And if anybody's specialty
is higher research,
it would be interesting
to get your insight first.
AUDIENCE: What you mean
by higher research?
AUDIENCE: Well,
if you're focusing
on an academic career
in a national lab,
you know more about
that than I would.
AUDIENCE: Where is
Lilly when you need her?
AUDIENCE: Yes, you got it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
think you probably,
as Cooke-Deegan laid it out,
you just really struggle
in this peer review process
if you have an idea for maybe
not a blockbuster drug
but a new approach
to a system that hasn't
really been tried out yet.
So that's what you see.
[INAUDIBLE] a mentor
have this huge problem.
And I think it
really is just kind
of allocating a part
of that NIH budget
that they get to this
DARPA-like high-impact, maybe
high-risk research and
then moving from there.
But I'm not sure
because it takes
so long to develop these
things, so a three to five year.
And then you have to figure
out clinical trials and things
like that like.
Would the time scale
need to be adjusted
to account for
doing the research
and then moving
into clinical trials
to be able to actually support
these high-risk initiatives.
And a lot of these
I feel like will
be building on research
that doesn't really exist
or isn't really there yet.
So we'll need more time
to stand up [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
think there's probably
two main ways that maybe
some of the later readings
touch on more.
But definitely,
incentives on the FDA
is hard to extend and make
that process a little bit more
profitable than, say, if it's
on an orphan drug where you have
a very small market that
could be addressed when
the drug comes out by
increasing the patent life
so they have extended
patent provisions
for those kind of drugs.
That definitely helps
make it more profitable.
And also, a lot of the later
papers talk about this.
But they have a
lot of flexibility
in the way they can
price their drugs.
So I think that kind of helps a
lot because if they can charge
a lot of money for a niche
drug that kind of compensates
for the fact that you're not
giving it to as many people.
AUDIENCE: And I guess my
concern with that last one
is what about a Martin
Shkreli situation?
AUDIENCE: I mean, yeah.
Obviously, that's
going to come up
because all these
companies will want
to recoup their costs
because they're spending
millions and billions of dollars
on these drugs to develop them.
And there is kind of an
argument for both ways
that it's kind of justified
but, I mean, obviously, bad
for society.
AUDIENCE: And also, you could
make a very similar argument
for any other drug in one
of these blockbuster drugs
as we say.
Because well, you
can still charge
an exorbitant price for them.
You can get tons
of money for them.
And then you're back to
square 1 where, OK, let's just
keep funding the
drugs that we've
been doing because don't fix
what isn't broken, right?
So I'm not sure how it would
incentivize people to focus
on these smaller drugs.
Now, one way you could do
it, maybe tax incentives
or something.
Maybe force insurance companies
to foot the bill a bit more.
But I don't really know the
detail on how that would work.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: This is one
of the great societal dilemmas
that we've get in health
care at the moment.
You want to create enormous
incentives for researchers
and the biotech
companies they may create
to go after these big problems.
You really want to
incentivize that process.
So if you start to
disincentivize it,
you're going to have less
remedies on the table.
On the other hand, you've
got serious cost problems
for some portion of
the population that's
not going to be able to cope
with the cost structure.
And you're going to
have real reluctance
on the part of
government agencies
to subscribe for a
huge cost burden that
only helps a relatively
small number of people.
So this is a dilemma that
is now upon us big time
that we have not sorted
through in an intelligent way.
And there's constant reviling
of drug and biotech companies.
But on the other
hand, they're the ones
that created these
opportunities for us.
So it's a very contradictory--
the politics doesn't seem
to recognize the importance
of the innovation system.
And yet we don't have the
right balance between the two.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [?
I was just going to answer ?]
[INAUDIBLE] the policy side,
or whatever
[? you want to say. ?]
AUDIENCE: Oh, I
actually was going
to say that also I think the
dimension that's also missing
is something we touched
on last week, which
is the ethical components.
I think there's really a rising
bioethics community surrounding
issues of utilitarianism versus
issues of human suffering.
Do we seek to address
the person who
is suffering the most
or the number of people
who are suffering?
And that is a really
difficult, I think,
ethical question
that has yet to be
addressed on a national level.
And I think it's easier--
I guess, I think about it
in terms of heuristics,
like short cuts for
decision making.
If we understand what our
values are nationally,
we can understand where to
begin to allocate money.
And if we sort out
our national values
in terms of the life
sciences and what
we think are our
national priorities,
perhaps maybe through a
referendum-like system,
I think it would
actually be a much more
efficient and accountable
way for the government
to make funding
priority decisions
rather than for life sciences
organizations and the NIH
to sort of make those
decisions for themselves
or for the citizens.
Because ultimately, this is
an issue at the human level.
And that implies
an understanding
of bioethical considerations.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I think that
tends to run into a problem,
however, with root attitudes
of the American population.
And I would say that a lot
of the American population
believes that we should
be allowed to live forever
because we're Americans.
So we should be eternal.
I'm exaggerating a bit here.
But there's a lot
of thinking along
those lines and a
lot of assumptions
that any cost, whatever it
is, is justified in terms
of the outcome for my health.
So these are these are
really tough decisions.
And the life science system
is now right up against this.
And the whole innovation model
is right up against these.
So these are these are
important considerations.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Just my concern with the
proposal as far as putting it
in the hands of
American people is
kind of what questions are
appropriate for letting people
to be answering versus
the ones that are experts.
[INAUDIBLE] A lot
of people would
debate that the Brexit
question wasn't really
something that the average
person could understand
well enough to make
an informed decision.
And so I guess if
you're asking strictly
what are your ethical
beliefs, vote on that.
I guess that's something
that people can vote on.
But if you're given
options of should we
fund something that will save x
number of people at this cost,
weighing that information is
more difficult than I think
the average person is willing to
put the time in to understand.
So I think that,
to some extent, NIH
and these kind of
organizations need
to make the decisions on what
our national priorities are
but, ideally, with
some input from us.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I want to push you
back to the issue that's
before us in this class, which
is the innovation organization
model that we've got here.
So we're looking at an
innovation organization that
evolved in a very
historical set of ways
where the problems, when
it was in the foundation
level, the scientific
problems turned out
to be different than
the way we see them now.
We tend to see that
there are a lot
of cross-cutting
scientific approaches
that cut across many
disease pathways that may
be critical for those diseases.
Whereas back then,
we saw, oh, there
will be one remedy
for each disease,
a much earlier-stage
scientific notion of disease.
And we're caught
up in that model.
And how do we bring change here?
We're up against a
legacy-sector problem
as we'll talk in a little bit.
How do we bring change
to that legacy sector
from an organizational
point of view?
AUDIENCE: I have not an
answer, but a non-answer.
I am going back to the attack
on peer review as it were.
I think that's a very odd place
to start in terms of something
to get rid of.
I think there were definitely
a lot of reasonable arguments
presented in favor of adopting
something a DARPA model.
And then going back
to your ethics--
you raised the point of
bioethics considerations.
It seems to me that peer
review in the system,
appearing to be the
values of peer review,
are so deeply ingrained
in the biopharmaceutical--
well, more on the biological
and medical research community.
It seems like it's very
much part of their values.
And it would be very
odd to me to see
them as separated out
because I can recognize
all of the detriments of
the peer review system
and how it can
favor incremental,
unimportant research over big
innovations and risk takers.
But it still seems like,
if you remove that barrier,
then you might have a
flood of ethical problems
that would just
start cropping up.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Look, I mean,
the DARPA model does not
work in all circumstances.
In other words, the DARPA model
is very much a top-down model.
A bunch of elite
program managers
are looking at
things they want out
of the end of the
innovation pipeline
and designing
projects to get there.
And we can certainly see why
there's room for this model,
for that kind of projects-based,
challenge-based model.
NIH offers the other
side of the coin.
Researchers propose
funding, and they
get funded based upon the
interest and quality of what
they're proposing.
That's very much
a bottom-up model.
In other words, a lot of
people can see a lot of stuff
in the bottom level
that a top-down model
can't necessarily see.
So Chloe, you're right.
It's not that you want to
replace NIH with DARPA.
I think what Robert
Cooke-Deegan would
say is maybe there's
room within a large NIH
entity for a DARPA like piece.
Just as there is in the
Defense Innovation System,
DARPA is only one element of
a much larger defense research
portfolio.
But it does provide some
interesting capability.
And peer review
does have advantages
from that bottom-up perspective
that a top-down strong program
manager perspective will not
necessarily be able to capture.
AUDIENCE: So from a
business perspective,
the thing I'm
wondering about is--
because there is this
trend right now called
social bonds, which
what they do is
they look at the parts of
society that are really wasting
a lot of money and
then they create
businesses to solve them.
And then they give a return.
That's why I asked about
the blockbuster drug.
Because you get to
find a blockbuster drug
is also a drug that
reduces a ton of costs
for the government.
And the business model is
the government is saying,
oh, we're spending $100 million
here to solve this problem.
We're going to send some of that
portion of the money to you.
And that's a good
way to cut the fat.
Because if the major
problem is we're
going to use all our budget
to solve these diseases--
there's probably a disease
that's 80% or a huge proportion
because it's not going to
be a linear relationship
with the cost.
My other concern
too was when you
said that they
doubled the budget,
this happens a lot in software.
So it's hard and
unintuitive to understand.
But it's like, say we're
going to have the lunch.
And I say, our
budget is $100,000.
Then I have to justify--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That
would be quite a lunch.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's the
thing because we're not just
eating, right?
It's like, OK, now, we have
to justify the $100,000.
Or a cool example
is right now there
is a startup in Silicon Valley
that spent like $120 million
to develop a juicer.
And so that you could only
juice with the machine.
And then a reporter was
like, I call your bluff.
And they squeezed
it with their hands.
And they did it.
So my concern is when
you have too much money,
you tend to have
to justify things.
And you come up with
this weird logic tree.
And you don't really
fundamentally solve
the problem.
In code, if there's a piece
code that one coder could do
and you put five people,
it actually complicates it.
It makes it way harder.
And now, you got
people infighting.
So that was my big
concern with that too.
AUDIENCE: I think-- and Martin
may be trying to get at it.
This kind of group
theory doesn't really
exists or kind of
breaks down in NIH
because it's really hard
to get these cross-cutting
technologies and encourage
that collaboration.
And I think what I really
want to see out of the DARPA
that they pull is not so much
get rid of the peer review
but start--
because DARPA has the ability
to pull these great groups
together and just call on
a lot of different folks
from a lot of different
areas and then direct them
towards a specific
research problem.
And I think where NIH
struggles is, yeah,
they might have a call
to say we want to get rid
of cancer or heart disease.
But there are a lot of
different folks working on it.
And not a lot of them, I would
say, probably work together
in tandem to really
figure out and solve
maybe one aspect of that
problem for maybe 10 years.
And then they focus
on a different aspect
of how a disease would
work in a different lab.
And I think NIH really
struggles in pulling together
these cross-cutting
technologies because there's
no one pulling them together.
And they just leave it up to the
discretion of the researchers
and scientists and
pharmaceutical companies
to come up with
incremental advances
rather than not only calling
for big calls or big research
projects but also
funding and making
it possible for great groups
to work on these research
projects.
AUDIENCE: Max
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Martin, you want
to give us some closing
thoughts on these two pieces?
Oh, I'm sorry, Max.
Did you--
AUDIENCE: I actually
had a quick question.
So given that this was published
21 years ago, give or take,
I'm curious--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Robert
Cooke-Deegan's piece, you mean.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Did NIH ever attempt
anything like this?
Because we've had some
significant time period.
Did they at least look at it?
Or did they decide, no?
AUDIENCE: And also, how
much criticism did he
get for publishing that?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It
was a threatening piece
to the NIH and life
science community,
frankly, arguing that there may
be an additional model that you
all need to consider.
So it was not received
with open arms.
Now, in fact, the current
NIH director, Collins,
has, early on in his
tenure as director,
latched onto the
problem that NIH
has got in doing translational
work-- in other words,
moving a technology
from the basic stage
into follow-on sectors
and doing the handoff
to the private sector.
So Collins began to
focus on that problem.
And there was discussion, at
that time, of doing something
like a DARPA.
So his effort to create NCATS
to do translational medicine,
the director that he hired
to head that new institute--
and he had to close
another one to do it--
actually really began
thinking seriously
about should there be DARPA-like
elements in this new NCATS
entity.
Chris Austin who
is that director,
very talented and very
interesting person, however,
just didn't have the resource
to set up a whole new entity
within his NCATS piece.
But so it's an
idea that continues
to kick around here and there.
And frankly, I would view it
as an interesting additional
feature for NIH to do some
things that it can't really
do without this kind of
organizational model.
So I think there's
organizational lessons here
that we can take from the
issues we've been reviewing
and apply it to a long
established research entity
to create new
things in the model.
How about some closing
thoughts, Martine?
AUDIENCE: I mean,
the closing thoughts
is that we discussed
the NIH model
and how it does work
for what they're doing
but also how there are a
lot of blind spots and areas
that aren't being touched into
I've been trying to solve.
And then we discussed
DARPA, which might
be a good way of solving it.
But it seems like it won't
fit in well with NIH.
But there is a structural
dissonance, I would say,
in terms of that this
form factor does not work
for these kinds of problems.
And it might also
be the groupthink
in the area that affects
their ability to solve
these kinds of problems.
So it might be better
for there to be a DARPA
NIH but not at NIH or nearby
because it might be too
difficult. And also, how do
you create natural incentives
for the researchers.
Because it seems like they
do these kind of leapfrogging
research initiatives
because it's a lot simpler
and they have a lot to
lose if they do fail.
And so how do you create
this kind of comfort zone
for researchers so that,
even if they do fail,
to get some kind of reward?
And how do they get recognition
for that sacrifice of their
what you call "academic career."
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
I mean, that's
another issue too,
which is having multiple
PIs on the problem.
It's complicated in
an RO1 award process
that focuses on the single PI.
Let me go onto the next
couple of readings.
And we'll do them as a pair.
So the Infectious Disease
Society of America
has this report called Bad Bugs,
No Drugs, which essentially
summarizes the whole problem.
And then the Food and
Drug Administration
has a paper on
innovation or stagnation,
which focuses on some of
the problems they face.
So let's do those.
And Chloe, do you have those?
Or Martin, do to
have one of those?
AUDIENCE: Do you have--
I know I have--
AUDIENCE: Which one?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Bad Bugs, No Drugs,
the Infectious Disease Society?
AUDIENCE: I can do this one.
I'm prepared for it, yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
Well, Chloe, which
one do you have?
You have the FDA one?
Innovation, stagnation.
All right, fine.
OK.
I mean, the title
gives this story away.
And this is the Infectious
Disease Society.
And they note that resistance
to bacteria, I think,
as everybody in this classroom
knows is very much on the rise.
And again, this report was
written a few years ago.
Two million people
in US hospitals
are going to get bacterial
infections in the hospital.
And 90,000 of them
are going to die.
That is a staggering
number, right?
We lose 30,000 people a year
in automobile accidents.
We're losing three times
that many in hospitals.
So talk about
tolerance for risk.
Americans haven't
fully woken up to this.
So hospitals are increasingly
a dangerous place to be.
And only two classes
of antibiotics
have been developed at
the time this was written
in the previous 30 years.
And one of those is
already facing resistance
in this kind of endless
cycle of build up
of resistance that bacterial
sources go through.
And by the late 1960s,
80% of staff bacteria
were penicillin resistant.
And in pneumonia,
40% of the infections
were resistant to one drug
and 15% to the next three.
So this is a serious
growing problem.
Yet because of the
blockbuster drug model,
there's no incentive for
drug companies or biotechs
to go after these antibiotics
because they cure the problem.
So you take the
antibiotic for two weeks,
and the problem is solved.
What you want, under the
blockbuster drug model,
is something that
I'm going to have
to take for the rest of my life
for $100,000 a year, right?
You don't really
want to cure it.
You want to create
incremental advances that
manage the problem.
Whereas the antibiotic
actually cures the problem.
So there's very little
incentive since there's
no economic return
model that works.
There's very little
incentive to go
after these antibiotic problems.
They work too well too fast.
So it's a very weak
return on investment.
And successful
antibiotics are just
too successful to justify
the investment cost.
So everybody is aware of this.
Elias Zerhouni, who preceded
Francis Collins as head of NIH,
had this roadmap model.
And this was certainly on that
list of cross-cutting issues
that need to be dealt with.
But how do you get
around the kind
of model here, the economic,
problematic blockbuster drug
model here?
So I mean there've been a
variety of ideas advanced.
There was bioshield legislation
to deal with biothreats.
But it could also bear
on infectious diseases.
The idea there was,
for a biothreat,
why would anybody develop
a biothreat remedy?
Because the drug
would only be sold
if there was a
completely unpredictable
terrible national disaster.
So are you going to take
all the risks and go through
the $1.4-billion clinical trial
process to develop a remedy
for something that may
well never be used?
A similar kind of problem
for antibiotic drugs.
So the Infectious Disease
Society said, wait a minute.
The same model that would
deal with biothreats, which
is that the
government would agree
to buy a certain
number of dosages,
a certain volume of
the remedy, at a set
price if you
developed the remedy.
So the risk on the
part of the government
is actually pretty low.
It only has to buy something
if you solve the problem.
But then of course, that's
what biotechs do anyway.
That's the economic
model they work off of.
So could the government
intervene in this sector
and, in effect, really change
around the risk-reward model.
So ideas like this
come to bear here.
We certainly haven't
solved this problem
and remains very much
with us but illustrates
what the issues are.
This other report from the
FDA, Innovation/Stagnation--
Challenge and Opportunity
on the Critical Path
to New Medical Products.
And both these reports, by
the way, have been updated.
I put the originals in, which
are fairly hard-hitting.
But they've been updated since
then by these organizations
so you can get later versions.
FDA does not have its own
substantial research arm.
NIH does the medical research.
Yet we're not doing
research on how
to get a better, more reliable,
and certainly speedier
evaluation and approval
process for FDA.
We don't have that.
There's nobody on that problem.
NIH does not view
that is their problem.
They view their
problem as developing
new drugs, new therapies, not
figuring out a safety approval
set of problems.
So nobody's really
on that problem
except for FDA's own fairly
modest research budget.
So the picture that
this report portrays
is ongoing breakthrough
scientific discoveries
that get nailed because the
drug approval process isn't
receiving new science
and new technology
advances that would
enable it to keep up
with these breakthroughs.
And we mentioned this earlier.
But the most serious one that's
ahead is in precision medicine
and personalized medicine
where it's developing a therapy
or a remedy that's uniquely
appropriate for you
as opposed to me, a
personalized medicine approach.
How are we going to do the
approval process for that?
How is FDA is going
to manage that?
So it is a dilemma
here in the system.
And again, it's an innovation
organization problem.
We've got an
innovation organization
that's focused on one
set of the problems.
And they've got the
resources do the R&D on it.
And yet we've got a
parallel big problem that's
jeopardizing the other system.
And we don't have the
organizational capability
of acting on it.
So then this is yet
another innovation
organizational
problem that, when
you think about these
things as systems,
you begin to identify
what the gaps are.
And here is one.
That's probably
enough on this topic.
So why don't we go right
into some Q&A on this.
Martine, you want to lead
us on Bad Bugs, No Drugs?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I guess the
main theme of this
is their way of using policy
or subsidies to incentivize
the private sector to
take on this problem.
Or even is the private
sector even the right entity
to handle this problem?
AUDIENCE: I feel like
a little suggestion
of having government
guarantee to pay
for a certain amount
of dosages seems
like a pretty good fix for it.
If you leave the free market
alone, these companies,
they currently don't
have an incentive.
So I don't think that's
really an option.
AUDIENCE: A professor of
mine, an economics professor
at Wellesley and Cornell is
very supportive of patent
extensions, which is something
that was cited in the report.
And she felt like, at
least in my understanding,
that would very much
motivate bio and pharma
companies to do
research primarily
because they're concerned
that their patents are
going to run out in the
lifecycle of the innovation
process.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And explain
how that would work, Steph?
AUDIENCE: Oh, man, I don't know
that I could do it justice.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Just briefly.
Give us a snapshot.
Or Chris.
AUDIENCE: So I think,
my understanding
of the patent-extension
process is that,
especially for orphan drugs
where it's like under like
10,000 people or
something like that--
so a smaller market size
or it's targeting children
like adolescents, you
get patent extensions.
And that could be three
to five years extra,
which is pretty significant
in terms of drug companies.
And yeah, I think those
are the main ones.
And there's also breakthrough
therapy designations.
And those not only help speed
up the approval process, which
is really valuable for these
companies that really want
to push through these
drugs really quickly
and get it to market.
And then they also extend a
little bit in certain cases.
So there's a lot of
different small ways
FDA is trying to
get more incentive,
which is nice to see.
I think it's a good policy.
AUDIENCE: And to add
a lower-order analysis
from microeconomics,
I think the way
that she explained it was
essentially-- and all of you
may know this.
I did not know this
until two years ago.
So maybe this is
new to someone--
is that researchers,
I mean, from the time
that they apply for
a patent, they have,
what is it, 15, 17
years or something
like that to
commercialization where
their patent is protected.
AUDIENCE: I thought it was 20.
AUDIENCE: 20?
AUDIENCE: It changed.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, it did.
[INAUDIBLE] is now 20 from 17.
AUDIENCE: So it used to be 17.
And now, it is 20.
And so the way that
she explained it to us
is that, because a lot of
the research-and-development
process could take
20 years by the time
they get a drug to
market, they may
have already lost the patent.
So it no longer becomes
economically advantageous
for the company to
pursue commercialization
of a particular therapy, and
thus what Chris was saying.
So that's just sort of
the small connections.
AUDIENCE: Separate concerns
sort of from like a scientific
or a biological perspective.
So I wonder if, is it that
these drugs are super effective
or antibiotics are
the best mechanism
to get rid of these
bacteria in the way
that we traditionally
think about them to say
that one is the way that
we think about bacteria?
Is that the actual
most effective means?
Or is that actually
how they work?
Or do we not
understand the pathways
of how they're
actually becoming more
resistant to these technologies?
So my question, is there just
like a group think in a way
that we think about antibiotics
and bacterial theory
in biology or in medicine.
We're just kind of following
along the same path.
So I would love to talk
to a bacteriologist.
And then 2, is this problem
one that we will ever solve?
Or will it just get
exponentially worse?
Because I can imagine,
even if we come up
with a faster and
faster mechanism
to get out these antibiotics
and reach more people,
will these bacteria just
kind of keep growing
and get faster
and more resistant
and we'll always
have this problem?
And then thirdly,
does that mean that we
should have an established
kind of entity within the FDA
that just deals with
antibiotics if they deem it
as a serious enough problem and
it's going to be persistent?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I can
try to speak to that.
AUDIENCE: The question
I was going to ask
is you can about
this theoretically.
But I was going to ask, so
if you had to start a company
right and you're relatively
young in your career
and this might be a
career-ender in terms
of if there's no success, what
incentives would incentivize
you to start a company or solve
this problem or an organization
to work on this exactly?
AUDIENCE: Presuming you have
the equipment and resources.
AUDIENCE: So antibiotics are
pretty difficult, first of all,
because they're becoming too
effective for their own good.
I think it was Pfizer or
one of the big companies
produce a very famous
kind of antibiotic drug.
And now, it's just so effective
that they've kind of become
a victim of their own success.
And also, it's also really
hard to pass antibiotic drugs
through clinical trials,
disproportionately so
compared to other diseases.
So that's also kind of
like a barrier to entry.
I think, honestly, if I were
to want to get into this field,
you have to come up
with a new approach,
something better than
is being done right now.
Because I think antibiotics
it's a very broad field.
There's so many
different strains.
And if they mutate
a bit your drug
can be already
rendered ineffective.
So it's just one of those
fields that is always evolving.
So not only do you have to
have very strong basic science
to keep up with what's
happening with these bacteria,
how are they like mutating, and
how are they kind of evolving,
and then you have to come up
with drugs to help target them.
So it's like a very
twofold problem
that you need to
simultaneously target.
And then obviously,
they're evolving
so rapidly that you have to
kind of pivot very quickly.
So I think it's one of those
fast-changing fields that
is kind of hard to target.
But definitely important.
I'm not really sure
what mechanisms
they have in place
or organization-wise
to kind of target
this specifically.
But I think it definitely
should be a focus.
AUDIENCE: You talked about
your pipeline getting approved.
What if they could speed
that up very quickly
so it's a priority?
AUDIENCE: I mean,
speeding it up would help.
But also, it's just hard to
produce a good clinical trial
for these drugs.
So I think that's also
a fundamental problem.
It's just like
psychiatric drugs.
Those are very notoriously
hard to prove because placebo
effect is really a big problem.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So that leads
us right into our
next reading, which
is this FDA problem and the fact
that we haven't put resources
on the drug approval process.
So Chloe, it's yours.
AUDIENCE: So if
we're starting off
with tackling that problem
of how do we sort of reform
and revamp the way in which
we evaluate these products,
one question for
you guys would be--
so the meeting
mentioned that one
of the things you could
attribute this mismatch
was a mismatch between the
levels of how far both research
in basic science and applied
science, where they put that.
They're very mismatched
in terms of one
of them is just shot ahead and
the other can't even keep up.
So what are your thoughts on how
or if an agency such as the FDA
should be responsible
for ensuring
the development of these
sciences are evenly matched?
For example, should
the agency bottleneck
the funding for basic sciences
until applied sciences
and catch up?
Or should they aggressively
stimulate opportunities
on other side?
AUDIENCE: I suppose
in an ideal scenario
you just stimulate that's more
funding to research drugs.
But I understand that there
isn't always money for that.
AUDIENCE: I forget--
but to that point,
there is another reading.
I forget if it was
this one or not.
But it said, just throwing money
and giving infinite budgets
isn't always the solution
because, in that case,
it takes away the
element of good planning
and strategic planning.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: The end
of innovation organization.
If you don't have the
innovation organization,
that's going to enable you to
avoid big gaps in the system.
You're just not
going to get there.
So throwing money at a problem
without tackling the innovation
organization problems
is problematic.
AUDIENCE: Ideally, yes.
Money in, money would--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, assuming that
you can use the money properly.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: One thing that
I was curious about.
I was confused how
antibiotics can simultaneously
be working too well
and you can have
tons of antibiotic-resistant
bacteria, which
implies that antibiotics
are not working too well.
So if someone could clarify
that, I would appreciate that.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That's yours, Chris.
AUDIENCE: So I think the problem
is that, say, Pfizer's drug is
doing really well.
So they give these
antibiotics to their patients.
And these patients
are getting cured.
And so that means, if
they're getting cured
and they're not really
getting these diseases,
that means that
drug is not going
to be really used as much.
And then at the same time,
because these patients
have used the drug, there is
antibiotic resistance growing.
And just because it's
been around for so long,
it's inevitable
that resistance is
going to build up to the
point that the drug is
no longer effective.
Because it's been
out for 10, 15 years.
AUDIENCE: But that
resistance can only
develop if lots of people
are using the drug--
AUDIENCE: I mean, obviously,
a lot of people have used it.
And it is, obviously, a
critical mass have used it.
It's been successful.
It's a really effective drug.
So maybe there's not
repeat people in the way
that other drugs might
have a lot of repeat users.
Maybe it's treating
a large population,
but people don't really
get the same kind
of strain of disease multiple
times, something like that.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And
Chris, part of the problem
is that we overprescribe
antibiotics
to an absurd extent.
And we're sticking antibiotics
in everything like hand soap.
And we're virtually guaranteeing
our own Darwinian dilemma.
AUDIENCE: It seems
to be applying
the language of this class
in previous lectures.
We're playing catch-up with
an innovation problem instead
of purely innovating,
which doesn't
seem like a very American
way to tackle this problem.
It's kind of odd
because it's almost
like we're being outplayed
by nature, which, I mean,
most of our big successes
over the last 200 or 300 years
have been us figuring out
how to manipulate nature
to our advantage.
So it's kind of an
interesting [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: I left my
American flag at home.
AUDIENCE: If that's
all we have for that,
I do have one more question
for the FDA reading,
more on the standard setting
sorts of things things.
What do you guys think,
again, are the roles
and responsibilities
of such an agency that
sets these standards
to encourage people
to take risks and
bring the slightly
riskier drugs to market?
Because the reading mentioned
that a lot of researchers
won't even go down that
path because they know how
arduous and tough [INAUDIBLE].
So is there something
the FDA could do to--
AUDIENCE: I like what Bill
said in terms of like,
OK, it's a very hard process.
But once you do it,
you're kind of set.
The only thing I would
question is I would tier it.
Because there's probably
different kinds of drugs
that have different specialties.
And they're probably
something that--
there's pretty
drugs that I really
want to get tested
really, really well.
Or there's some that,
even if I do test them,
I still don't know and some
drugs that can probably get
passed faster.
So I would figure out like
how does this scheme work.
Look at the data in terms of how
are these drugs being passed,
how long does it take, which
ones were relatively quick
and see if I could restructure
the organization so that I
can optimize for the
stuff that really matters
and the stuff that doesn't
really matter as much,
it's not a focus.
So we're having a linear kind
of everything is the same.
AUDIENCE: So are you saying
maybe make the funding
or whatever a function of, say,
quality and the amount of time
it would take to get passed so
then, if you need a drug that
maybe would only work for a
few people, you can make it
so it would be
really high quality.
Whereas if you have
a drug that needs
to work for a lot of people
that you need really quickly,
then you can make
it so that it's
less robust or for fewer
restraints, et cetera,
embracing something like that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
something like that.
Because you also think
about compound interest.
So say I know that,
if I make this drug,
I'm going to save the government
like $50 million a year
or $80 million a year
over four or five years.
So if it's something that's
going to make a big impact,
how about we go faster
and we can iterate faster?
So we have priorities for drugs
that really, really matter.
I don't like the argument of
saying, oh, not a lot of people
are going to use it so we're
not going to prioritize it.
And let's put it in the back
because it's kind of false.
Or maybe you should create
another organization that
only focuses on
those kinds of drugs
and split up the FDA
into one that focuses on
that so it gets equal review.
But that's kind of
a same wavelength.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
just to kind of summarize
here from your all good
presentations and good
questions, the FDA is sitting
on a really critical part
of the problem.
So if we could significantly
speed the drug approval process
and if we could
significantly lower its cost,
we solve a lot of problems here.
We can be much less reliant
on a blockbuster drug model.
So it seems to me that, in
terms of the panoply of fixes
to this gap in the
innovation system,
really paying attention
to how to accelerate--
Martine, as you
were pointing out--
the review process at FDA.
And it's very hard to
reduce safety requirements.
It's just not going to be
acceptable to the public.
But if there are new ways of
using big data and analytics
and simulation and
modeling, those potentially
present very significant
improvements to this process
here that could really
help tackle this problem.
So putting some money
on that one I think
could be really key.
Then we go back
to NIH, NIH is not
organized around those kinds
of technology problems.
So how are we going to do this?
So we have another
dilemma as soon
as we arrive at the answer.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: I mean, just as we
transition into Bill's reading
about this being a legacy sector
or exhibiting a lot of legacy
features, I'm curious about
what you, Bill, or the class
thought about the
political viability of,
I guess, in terms of
Martine's proposal
toward a tiered approach.
If we thought it was more
politically viable to do this
for either therapeutic drugs
or for cure-all interventions,
there seems, in my very limited
study of the life sciences,
to be a proclivity towards
the therapeutic drugs
and interventions
because they're more
sustainable and profitable.
So do we think that that
could be a potential market
opportunity to test
a DARPA-like system
or to test the sort of
improved speed of acceptance
of the drug?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Let me throw
that back to the group here.
AUDIENCE: I like the point--
I forgot when we mentioned it
about how drugs were too low.
So they want to have
recurring revenue.
But I think, as the
government, you get a lot of,
you have to pay that.
So it would be interesting
if the government
is like, OK, well, we
know, over the lifetime,
if we don't solve
this now, it's going
to cost us one million
dollars for this person.
So you solve it
today, we're going
to give you $20k, which
is way cheaper for us
overall in the long term.
But you're not getting paid
$10 per drug or $100 per drug.
And so it's kind of a
win-win because it's really
good revenue for
the company and it
justifies having a super drug
that really, really works.
And it gives them enough
money on their balance sheet.
I don't know if you guys know
how Warren Buffett got rich.
But he got an insurance company.
And they give him a lot
of cash so that they
can invest in other companies.
And it's really good for
companies having a lot of cash
on hand.
AUDIENCE: Who'd have thought?
AUDIENCE: Well, no, it's
just like a lot of them
don't have a lot of cash
on hand at any given time.
So they have their assets
distributed between physical.
And so it's really good to be
able to move quickly and buy
all this stuff.
And it's just not a thing
that happens that easily.
There's also a lot
of tax benefits.
That's why people do it.